alors jamais le moment où il ya eu les
émeutes dans les banlieues j'ai demandé
de venir sur le sur le plateau de tout
le monde en parle pour vous exprimer
pour en parler pour témoigner et kader
aoun et vous m'avez répondu on a fait un
spectacle ça oui ça fait 20 ans qu'on
entendait faire dd mais avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour toi j'adore venir
ici c'est vrai mais tu as eu raison
parce qu'on a passé l'extrait du
spectacle et c'était très pertinent et
tout le monde a été d'accord avec ça
mais remercie idée merci parce que je
sais c'est vrai que le petit monde ça
fait vous savez 20 ans que que je monte
sur scène que je passe d'associations
l'association pour gueuler à qui vous
veut bien entendre qu' il y a des
problèmes chez nous mais
j'étais très surpris de voir à quel
point ça avait surpris les gens
c'est vrai ça m'avait sera étonné de
voir à quel point les gens étaient mes
mouvements des ponts de cé sympa c'est
tout a brûlé ouais bien sûr tout a brûlé
ya des gens qui souffrent personnes deux
enfants
voient le climat il un peu bizarre en ce
moment je trouve s'est fait insulter par
finkielkraut est touchée que la dernière
fois que juliette est venu ici
finkielkraut l'a fait pleurer c'est pas
vrai petit a fait pleurer je me
défoncerai l'embrasser
qui t'a fait plus rêver les grands pas
voir de quel bois je me chauffe ont
énoncé leurs héros
ouais mais est ce que c'est vraiment à
cause de lui c'est pas le mec qui trouve
que l'équipe de france c'est la honte
parce qu'elle est trop black black black
ils voulaient casser quelques quelques
que des barrages partout alors peut-être
non non c'est largement on n'aurait même
pas bacula la vallée de chevreuse
le mexique est au delà si leur relation
c'est cela ce qui m'étonne c'est que
c'est c'est vraiment il ya des cons
laisse passer pas mal de choses quand
même tu vois je te jure ça m'a rappelé
1965 moelleux le
couvre-feu c'est ça rassemble au début
de la guerre d'algérie nous en c1 c'est
des vrais signaux forts
cc c'est un bourgeois qui arrivent avec
des caméras et qui regardent des petits
robots sont pas jumeaux qui leur dit je
vais vous nettoyer au kärcher bande de
racailles
c'est tournez manège pour moi sur un
terrain il s'est penché sur le sens du
mot banlieue un
peuple épris zab la racaille c'est ça
que ça veut dire ça mais un dictionnaire
ces sports lieu ces lieux de
bannissement fait de bannissement
jusqu'où alors non
peuple méprisable on va vous mettre dans
un lieu banny
a abandonné c'est ça que ça veut dire et
c'est des mecs qui
nicolas sarkozy vraiment j'ai rien
[ __ ] en lui d'ailleurs nicolas et
quand monsieur nicolas sarkozy si vous
m'écoutez
beau boulot très très beau boulot c'est
sûr et certain
c'est comme ça qu'on y arrive en
question
le sultan des gens parce que tu leur dis
quand même le karcher c'est fait pour
nettoyer la merde un si beau si tu as
entendu parler et c'est pour nettoyer la
merde donc ils considèrent que les gens
qui habitent en banlieue c'est de la
merde c'est ça qu'on entends tu vois il
est la critique critique et matin midi
et soir des ghettos les ghettos de
pauvres ils créent des ghettos de riches
le mec à neuilly c'est sa ville lui on
est d'accord il ya que 2 % de logements
sociaux il devrait y en avoir 20 alors
le mec qui défend nos lois il est déjà
hors la loi
photo jg je le trouve marrant je le
trouve sympa moi ce mec et je trouve
juste qu'il est là pouf tu as dit c'est
très triste pour les gens qui ont pris
des crédits pour acheter des fiat panda
mais je suis content qu'il se passe
quelque chose mais attends je sais pas
si tu te rends compte mais jacques
chirac il est venu parler à la
télévision ce que maintenant il faut
pour un rendez vous avec chirac il faut
d une année bissextile dans
la dernière fois ici on la voit quelques
phrases avec guy bedos
sont gentils c'est de la souffrance
après bien sûr compris les bagnoles du
magsafe
personnes pas d'accord avec ça mais on
crie quand on a mal une crise où on
pleure et on crie en fait mal quand on a
mal est vraiment faut arrêter la chaîne
et si effectivement il ya un mec qui
lance dakar cheikh des mots non mais qui
ont fait ça sont eux ces jeux mal moi
j'entends que le voile et je vois des
gens qui ont mal et ça me fait mal les
gens vivent mal moi quand je l'aï
entendu dire aux à la télévision que
effectivement français françaises il ya
des discriminations dans ce pays ça
marche toujours je me suis dit tiens ça
fait plaisir alors moi qui sont la
perçoit ils arrivent ils débarquent on a
la pression et puis derrière il nous
propose des solutions qui sont tout sauf
des solutions nous avec mon gouvernement
travaillons sur la question mais pour
l'instant elle vous donnera une réponse
ultérieurement
y'a pas que il ya juste en face de nous
des gens qui n'arrêtent pas d'occulter
le fait que re souffre et c'est vrai que
l'ambiance est un peu pourri en ce
moment ça pue un peu je sais pas si tu
as remarqué comment ça tu es en train de
tuer la capacité d'une manière générale
c'est pas d'accord trouve ça un peu que
ça a pu ceux qui sont d'accord ce qu'on
ne s'appuie pas vraiment
nicolas sarkozy s'est tu les écoutes ça
paie en cependant il faut mettre du
blizzard gouvernementale
alors vous dites jamais devant vous
dites que vous êtes contre le mot
intégration parce que vous dites qu'il
n'ya pas besoin d'être intégrée vous
êtes français donc elle a bien sûr
besoin de vous intégrer n'a été fournie
aux histoires intégré vous êtes français
voilà et visitent ces gosses sont mal et
les seules personnes qui leur tendent la
main viennent des mosquées les mecs qui
viennent les voir il leur propose de
faire des rouges c'est ce qu'on appelle
des sorties à strasbourg pour aller
prêcher lille marcq en baroeul en italie
pour prêcher la bonne parole alors il y
en a qui sont sincères et qu'on
véritablement la fois et puis dans tout
ça t'a débat car qui profitent de la
situation et sait si il s'est enfoncé
ses gosses dans l'obscurantisme et signe
la responsabilité de la france que de
leur proposer des ddd d'ouvrir leur
école c'est une galère de rentrer à
sciences po et l'ena comment c'est
possible si c'est une galère de trouver
du taf comment c'est possible ça c'est
une galère de trouver du taf alors bien
sûr ils ont trouvé il ya des solutions
aux baisse les impôts des riches mais je
sais c'est pas d'appel moi je devrais
être content je suis riche j ai rien à
[ __ ] je te jure c'est pas comme ça
qu'on va réussir à alors rendre service
à eux une solution c'est d'aller voter
et pour aller voter faut d'abord
s'inscrire c'est ça pour s'inscrire faut
se dépêcher parce qu'en fait on peut pas
s'inscrire en 2006 faut s'inscrire avant
la fin du mois de décembre ouais et puis
il faut cesser plus efficace que de
brûler des flaques pente à
s'organiser aller voter c'est un c'est
là c'est la seule manière de pouvoir
leur dire qu'on n'est pas d'accord et de
se battre pour leurs propos pour nos
propres idées il faut arrêter de créer
des clans c'est juste ça faut arrêter de
faire croire à la france entière qu'on
ait des voleurs des bandits et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de leonard youtube
abonnez vous il mettait un peu de bleu